وكحل متكامل وجهها الدوله المصريه جهوده
نحو انشاء مركز اقليمي متخصص في نقل
وزراعه الاعضاء الفكره التي حبق عليها
السيد الرئيس المرتبطه بانشاء اول مركز
متكامل لزراعه الاعضاء والتكامل هنا نعني
به التكامل من الناحيه الفنيه الانشائيه
الاداريه الرقميه همم
وكمان يشمل نوعيه العمليات التي تجر فاحنا
هنا مش بنتكلم على مركز متخصص في زراعه
الكلى او الكبد او ال- البنكرياس او
النخاع او القلب فقط احنا نتكلم على مركز
يشمل كل ذلك بما فيها همم زراعه الرئه
زراعه القرنيه همم
ويصلحه
المركز الذي همم يتعامل مع كل المراكز همم
البيانات تنقل من جميع المراكز الى هذا
المركز
اقليمي في مصر يوفر همم
الاعضاء للناس المحتاجينها اا فكره عظيمه
جدا لان في ناس بجد مش بتقدر على انها
تسافر للخارج ما عندهاش همم يعني معونه
ماديا انها تسافر الخير فلما يكون في
الحاجه دي في بلدي فدي حاجه عظيمه جدا همم
من الخطوات برده والايجابيه اللي حصلت
الفتره اللي فاتت ان احنا لقينا خبر ان
الرئيس بيستعد ان هو يعمل اكبر مركز في
الشرق الاوسط للتبرع بالاعضاء بعض الوفاه
دي كانت بالنسبه لنا همم فرحه يعني جميله
جدا لان دي هتشجع ناس كثيره ما دام الدوله
دخلت في الموضوع يبقى الناس هتتشجع ان هي
تنزل وتعمل اقرار لان في خطوه فعلا فعليا
ابتدت
ان انتشار ثقافه التبرع بالاعضاء وتفعيل
القانون المنظم لذلك سيفتح باب الامل من
جديد امام الاف المرضى من الذين يعانون من
الفشل الكلوي والتهاب الكبد الوبائي ولمن
يحتاجون لفص كبد او رئه ليس هذا فقط بل
سيقضي تماما على مافيا تجاره الاعضاء
البشريه ويعزز ويعظم من فكره العطاء وان
الانسانيه هي مظله للخير تجمع الانسان
باخيه الانسان
كنت بقعد احيانا بقول جون هيكون مستقبله
ايه يعني في سن 10 سنين كان ابني طبعا
فاقد السمع فاقد ان هو يوصل له معلومه
اييه كامله فكنت بقعد احيانا كده بيني
وبين نفسي اعيط على مستقبل ابني اول ما
شفته بيكون لوحه وبيرسمها حسيت بتعويضات
ربنا يعني هي دي اللحظه اللي حسيت ربنا
بيقول لي اهو همم اللي كنت خايفه عليه
اللي يعني ربنا مسؤول عنه ما بتخافش عليه
وانا واثقه ان ربنا بجد ان هو هيدخل في
امر جون من ناحيه زراعه الكبد